now to the battle on the border now
security rages on there in Texas the
Lone Star State now adding even more
razor wire and fencing to an Eagle pass
Park and Fox News cameras were rolling
capturing their pre-assembly Matt Finn
live from Eagle Pass Texas and Matt
bring us up the date where we are now
hello and good
morning well Bill our viewers know for
years now we've been reporting from
inside this park and migrants have been
a able to freely cross into this park
and the United States well now over the
past week or so we have not seen any
large groups being able to get inside of
this park there is row after row of
razor wire and fortification and it
seems like it is working Texas is also
now arresting migrants who illegally
cross into Texas under governor governor
Abbott's new emergency declaration Texas
DPS says last night it arrested three
men for Criminal Trespass after they
crossed through the razor wire one man
that was from Ecuador door also today
the Texas National Guard is scheduled to
install hundreds of yards of additional
fencing and razor wire to bolster this
park border this is pretty much in
defiance of the lawsuit between the
Biden Administration and Texas the
federal government wants full access to
this park and the ability to potentially
remove razor wire as it sees fit now all
this is happening in Maverick County we
talked to a Democratic candidate for
County Commissioner Yolanda Ramon
Yolanda is also the former democratic
mayor proem of Eagle Pass Yolanda tells
us she gives vice president Harris a
quote ne30 failing grade as borders are
and yulanda says most people in this
region would praise Republican Governor
Abbott for seizing this
park he's helping a lot more than
anybody has here you know again I know
that's a controversial issue here
because I know there a lot of people
don't want to hear that but if you live
here if you're here in the
community then definitely I mean we
thank thank
you and also worth noting Texas kicked
out federal border patrol Agents from
inside of this park but we have noticed
uh border patrol airboats on the river
so it appears that the state of Texas is
allowing Federal border patrol access of
the boat ramp here in this park they
just don't want them interfering with
their mission here on land Bill okay
Matt thanks Matt Finn that ongoing story
there from the border Dana I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis